we have nebula played by Karen Gillen
hello Karen
there are so many use tonight
so many nebulas you all
look it's not an easy makeup to cosplay
I know I appreciate you and you would
know if someone has played this for
almost a full decade what is this
journey and transformation of being to
play Douglas for so long what is this
meant for you oh everything it's been
such a complete honor to get to play
this role and to be a part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like how often do you
get to say something as crazy as that um
and it's been amazing and I love my
character so much I love playing her so
it's been like a an incredible 10 years
well you're willing to do almost
anything for this character in the first
film for Guardians of Galaxy vol 1 we
heard that you shaved your head I did I
saved all of my hair off I mean it's
grown back lovely but is there anything
you kind of done for this film as well
that tops that at all well I kind of
negotiated more hair with each movie so
now I get to keep my hair but it does
mean that I add an extra hour onto the
makeup time in the morning because they
have to wrap it under a bold cap so
unsub you lose them straight off now you
know in this film you know we're seeing
you are now part of the Guardians family
uh but you know so much of the films
have really been about you and your
relationship with uh Gamora and now that
Gamora is not here but it's a different
Gamora how is nebula dealing with the
loss of that sister and moving forward
with her Guardians family well we're
seeing a very different sights in nebula
this time around uh now that Thanos has
been like eliminated from her life and
he's the source of all her trauma she's
actually starting to develop a little
bit more of a later personality there's
a little more levity to her and a little
more sense of humor which is a kind of
new sort of space for her to to live in
and as for Gamora it's almost like
they've switched places in an
interesting way nebulas now the more
evolved character with more compassion
and so she kind of needs to help Gamora
in that respect well you are such a
bubbly person and nebula is becoming a
little bit of a lighter character now do
you feel like you relate to her more in
any way I always relate it to her
yeah because I think that even though
nebula was very serious at the beginning
she was someone that is dealing with a
lot of the same issues that everybody
deals with
um and so I've always related to her and
it's just been kind of fun to inject her
with a little bit more of my own sense
of humor this time around we have loved
seeing you play this role over the past
decade and we can't wait to see this
tonight now you have anything you want
to say to the fans before we go
I love you you're the greatest fans of
the world truly
oh the passion it's it's electric and
contagious so thank you